طبعا المساعدات الماليه كما ذكرنا هي جزء
من الدعم الذي تستخدمه الدول المتضرره من
الكوارث في اعاده الاعمار جهه عند قدمت
مساعدات لسوريا وتركيا بعد الزلزال لكن
بجانب الدول هناك حملات جمع تبرعات من اجل
الضحايا ومن اجل اعاده الاعمار مثلا في
تركيا جمعت حمله تركيا قلب واحد اكثر من
سته مليارات دولار في بث مباشر على الهواء
في سبع ساعات فقط سوريا الى جانب تبرعات
دول وهيئات حول العالم لاجئون بالملايين
السوريون 13 مليونا حول العالم حاول بعضهم
المساعده في ولايه تنسى اللاجئ السوري
ياسين تيرو جمع اكثر من
186 الف دولار لاغاثه المتضررين من
الزلزال ومن بينها مواد غذائيه ياسين لم
يكتفي بذلك بل ذهب لتركيا من اجل توزيع
المساعدات وضمان وصولها لمستحقيها بعضها
يتم نهبه كما ذكرنا في حلقه الامس رحله
ياسين تابعتها كاميرا الساعه ستون
[موسيقى]